la région de montmagny jusqu'à
rivière-du-loup attire les oies blanches
et les causes électorale série weeds
s'essaieront paris pour acquis c'est
vraiment très serré on le voit ici c'est
une course r et depuis la fin des 2000
et j'ai ma quatrième élection et j'en ai
eu deux qui ont été extrêmement serrée
dans le passé sans que l'on ait perdu
j'ai gagné la dernière le député
conservateur et le candidat à battre
dans cette élection il s'est bâti un
fort capital de sympathie en sillonnant
la circonscription sans relâche depuis
quatre ans cav à savoir le temps forts
oui moi je rage en effet beau le
politicien qui est aussi un homme
d'affaires visite les entreprises aient
fait leur promotion sur facebook ça a
donné 4 49 personnes qui ont été
touchées a passé une visibilité
appréciée même parce qu'ils ne voteront
pas pour le parti conservateur
je suis qu'un mot l'environnement ce
quelque chose de très important
on en parle on en parle des beaux
discours finalement opel sa part en
avance et 2005 en 2050 entreprises on
est bien on est pas sorti bio enfin une
culture responsable qui entre c'est
important la vigneronne avoué trois
tirés par le bloc québécois qui fait une
remontée spectaculaire dans la région
vous connaissez le bloc québécois
j'imagine une canaille poser un regard
des crs en maille code vous malgré un cv
depuis qu'il a grandi louis gagnon est
devenu enseignant de littérature au
cégep et candidat bloquiste ses
adversaires admettre qu'il a le vent
dans les voiles plus un gros chien à
part à la télévision plus alliés aux
conservateurs parce que les québécois
s'aperçoivent qu'ils veulent pas être
représentée par quelqu'un qui a des
valeurs de catholiques extrémistes c'est
les mots qui font un poignet quand on
est contre l'avortement pour des raisons
religieuses
les québécois le ils veulent rien savoir
moi je suis pro choix j'ai toujours dit
je traite à la tuer je respecte mon chef
qui est pro vie j'ai aucun problème à
réaction aucun aucun problème avec ça et
ils ont été extrêmement clair qu'on
aurait ouvrir jamais le débat me sujet
des rues c'est une personne qui est
apprécié dans monsieur qui est gentil
qui est proche des gens par contre
qu'est ce qui fait à ottawa
nous ce qu'on se fait dire ce qu'ils
disent pas grand chose donc c'est
là-haut moi je veux faire la différence
le cinéaste hugo latulippe fait ses
premiers pas en politique il apprend à
marcher sur des oeufs avec les maires de
la mrc de montmagny
secteur le plus conservateur de la
circonscription le npd a mis
l'environnement au dessus de tout le
reste
les arguments en faveur d'une révolution
écologique ne raisonne pas du tout
auprès de ses élus presque tous
favorables en troisième lieu entre
québec il arrive sur juste point de vue
économique moi je dis on n'est pas mieux
dans le préfet l'autobus si vous avez
fait votre campagne électorale juste en
train de nettoyer loin une région c'est
certain parce que le service est pas bon
faire cette révolution de notre économie
ce c'est compliqué c'est long il faut
prendre le temps il ya des nuances
c'est ça que je trouve difficile
d'expliquer ces choses leur rapidement
que pensez-vous de la loi le premier
ministre est très claire on va aller
avec le ce que les gens veulent et puis
ça c'est très clair que c'est ce que les
gens veulent c'est la loi 21 depuis que
justin trudeau a dit qu'il pourrait
contester la loi sur la laïcité
plusieurs candidats libéraux au québec
ont de la difficulté à défendre la
position de leur chef
moi je suis favorable à cette fois lors
pourquoi on doit ne plus arborer tout ce
qui est religieux quand on travaille
pour pour le gouvernement
je me présente à la dengue le vaudou
tech candidat pour le parti libéral
fédéral les électeurs rencontrés par les
candidats que nous avons suivi était
presque tout son corps est d'ici cette
femme hésite entre indochine et jack 8
singh je trouve que ça monsieur
surpris dans ses mots il ya la ravoire
vraiment plaire à l'humain et puis je
sens plus à naître la douceur de ses
mots et quand même deux j'ai fait la
boussole électorale oui ok ok de
radio-canada l'accord puis qu'est ce que
ça donne cette boussole le geda j'ai
logé par sa donné par le barça on espère
avoir aussi la balance du pouvoir au
niveau de polluants j écoute poliment
son visiteur mais ce qu'il souhaite
surtout c'est un gouvernement
minoritaire ou majoritaire
s'il devient totalitaire et césar est
sauvé par la cloche
il doit aller sortir les failles du four
comme beaucoup d'indécis il se donne
jusqu'au 21 octobre
pour trancher
[Musique]